the jurogan experience there's so much
stuff that we kept from the story
that that if i told you you wouldn't
believe me now when it came to the movie
we filmed it around the gunfight like
what so
we filmed it the movie around the gun
fight because that's when everyone was
alive
i was like you shouldn't have known that
i was gonna be the guy to make it out
when they were picking the actors i was
like so if you get somebody
like an a-list actor and then everybody
they'll know that that he's the one that
made it out i was like when you're
watching the movie you shouldn't know
that
of course hollywood does kind of kind of
kind of does their own thing
but the craziest part about that whole
operation was getting me out of there
and that wasn't in the movie in the
movie they did a daylight daylight
extract like they came in landed
a couple of shots and they got out of
there in real life it wasn't like that
it was unbelievable i mean
it was a night
and the i mean the world was blowing up
we were in this like a volcano
like sitting in the middle of this
volcano and i remember looking down the
mountain
there's there was a there was a river
running down i mean it looked like miles
down
and they had moved me they had to carry
me i couldn't walk and they kind of like
and they they
we would stumble over the green berets
rangers it was a hodgepodge
let me tell you something when them guys
showed up to rescue me
when they found me i was laying in a in
a riverbed
dried up tucked under a rock the the
villagers had shoved me underneath this
rock
and there was this one guy i had never
met before
and he was sitting there listening to a
am fm radio
and he was scrolling through the
channels
we hand those out for morale like the
the u.s military hands those and he had
one of them i recognized it and he was
listening to the different channels and
i could recognize the different
languages
german japanese and he was like hey
they're talking about you
and i was like okay i didn't know who he
was he's kind of messing with me
a little bit because i would i couldn't
move and he had to sting in
anyways it's not important and then um
then the the guru law and a couple of
the villagers came in and picked me up
they had to carry me everywhere and they
why
why
did they save you because in the movie
it's confusing
it is because in the movie it's like
these guys save you and you don't
you don't know why they're saving you
when he found me
they have to fight the taliban yeah can
you believe that crazy
so i had been crawling for a day and
some change
i was like crawling through the
mountains and i had somehow someway got
to the top of this ridgeline
i was so thirsty i mean i
but i thought about this
there's an insanity that goes with
thirst i was so
i was so thirsty that i was willing to
kill anything to get water i was go i
mean you can't even believe it i was
drinking my own urine my own blood
nothing would quench the thirst i hadn't
thought about this in a while and i got
to the top of this
ridge line and there was a waterfall and
i was trying to slide down into it i was
like i'm just gonna go down in here and
i'm going to hit that water and it's
going to be something good to drink
so i tried to slide down i just took off
i got
uncontrollably i started sliding i
rotated upside down
and i remember looking over and my rifle
was sliding beside me
i couldn't throw that thing away it's
like every time i lose it one of my boys
are like hey you're gonna need this
and i flipped into upside down over
backwards into the river
and i remember my knees hit me in the
face and it knocked me out again and i
was kind of
i mean i was i was blobbering mess
everything was broken
and i i rolled over and i remember kind
of sitting on all fours i picked my head
up and i looked up and there was that
water fountain there and i remember
sliding down this is the craziest thing
i had thought about this and i remember
seeing this little pool of water and i
was like oh it'd be a great place to get
something to drink
so i climbed i crawled back up into this
thing and i leaned into that waterfall
and i remember washing my face and hands
my gloves were i had gloves on the
mechanic gloves and all the fingers were
ripped out and the palms were ripped out
so i just kind of and it was the best
water i ever had
i'll never forget it it's cold
and uh i was hurting real bad and i
remember hearing somebody screaming at
me
and i kind of turned around over my
shoulder there's a guy standing there
looking at me pointing at me he was like
taliban taliban
so i swung around with my rifle and then
all of a sudden behind me again there
was i could hear someone screaming at me
they're like
and i look up and there's this guy
standing on the hill that i've just
fallen off of
but he didn't have a weapon he was just
pointing at me and then there were some
guys on the ridgeline moving around they
had weapons
i saw him so i turned back around
and i kind of started to crawl i was
like man i was in a channelized area
it was kind of bad and i i remember i
was leaning against this rock i was
sitting on my
my butt i had my rifle man i was
breathing i couldn't breathe i bit my
tongue in half and i was like
that was a crazy story but
the guy screamed at me again i turned
around to shoot and he he saw me and he
dug behind this rock and then i mean
right over my left shoulder
probably 30 yards not even that
i hear american american and i kind of
turned around and it was uh gulab
one of the main villagers who rescued me
and i turned around on him i had my gun
at my hip
my safety was off my attention was out
of my trigger and he was kind of looking
i mean we were staring each other
straight in the eyes
and i i mean i was like like death
you know how you can smell death when
it's there i was like man okay let's go
and uh yeah
i don't know why i didn't kill him i
don't know why i didn't
i didn't have to even go to my shoulder
to kill him i mean i had the tension out
of my trigger
i was just sitting there looking at him
he was looking at me and he was he
wouldn't say
he said american a couple of times then
he said it again i was like taliban
and he was like american and then he
kind of put his hands up and i came off
my trigger
kind of wanted to kill him
and he started walking down on me he's
like okay okay okay okay
shampoo hydrate shampoo hydration he's
telling me shampoo
that's what he said two english words he
knew i was like shampoo hydrate
you know how good that sounded i was
like bro i would love some water and if
you want to wash my hair
it's so funny so if you ever get into a
bad situation and you're about to lose
your mind just stay shampoo and hydrate
and you'll be fine dude i'm like
can you believe that that's what he said
to me that's crazy
and i dropped my muzzle down and he
walked up on me and i pulled a grenade
out
i pulled the pin don't ever do that and
i was gonna like if you try something
i'll just kill us all i don't care
but then he kind of rolled me over and
he's like it's okay i got you you know
i could just tell you know how when you
can tell like hey man i got you
i freaking got you you can feel that
like you can feel if someone's like hey
man i i got you and then i'm gonna jack
you up later and this guy was like man i
got you man
and i re-pinned that grenade i'll never
forget i was like i heard you're not
supposed to
i mean there's so much crazy stuff
anyways all these kids came running out
from everywhere and they picked me up
i couldn't walk and they carried me down
started carrying me down the ridge line
into the
into the valley there was a village down
there
and then the kids and everybody they
were laughing and and whatnot and they
pulled me into this room
and they started kind of doctoring they
doctored me up stopped my bleeding
patched me up gave me all the water i
could drink and then the taliban came in
after that and then
snatched me up but so how much of what
what was in the script i know you didn't
see the movie but
how much of what was in the script was
accurate
every bit of it everybody died
like in the movie when you see those
guys falling down a mountain looks cool
imagine going past cool to when it looks
like chaos
imagine playing your favorite sport on
the side of a mountain with people
shooting at you
it didn't look cool i was like it looked
terrific sexy
i mean i i it was terrible i mean like
it's
getting ripped apart and like we would
come in and the guys would just be
like matt was shot in the face and it
was kind of
his eyes were gone
like i'm a medic
some of them were bad someone was bad
but then you know i was like
i didn't know what to do i just started
i never knew what to do
ain't that crazy i was like man it's
well trained i was like i got my ass in
a pickle i couldn't get out i didn't
know what to do
and i would just sit there and there'd
be times when i when i would talk
thinking about my brother and all my
buddies i was like hey man you guys have
done stupid i'm still here come get me
and then i could see aircraft flying
overhead and i was like i'm right here
and they would just keep flying
and then someone was trying to kill me
like a wall would blow up or a bullet
would zip through the wall
and then they'd have to move me man it
was a hell of a week
it was rough
they left me in this hole for a while
they buried me
and uh i was like man i'm a foreign man
a foreign land everybody's dead
i know i mean who knows where i'm at i
was in hell
i was literally in hell and if it wasn't
for them
i mean and the way that whole thing
worked out
i i
it's funny what i talk about it's it's
hard to
wrap your head around it right like man
why am i even sitting here because y'all
came and got me i couldn't believe it
i couldn't believe it when y'all showed
up i signed up to be an expendable asset
to die if necessary that was the sexiest
thing i ever heard of i was nobody
i'm you know i have a special skill i
was
expendable asset and you work till you
become dependable and they'll kind of
keep you around
so when you all showed up i couldn't
believe it i couldn't believe it
i remember talking to them guys like man
i can't believe you all made it out here
we were out in the middle of nowhere
and then and then um the first time i
ever got like scared
was when they when they were with me and
trying to get me out of there i was like
hey man i hope y'all can get me out of
here
is that selfish i was like man that's
selfish is it
i was like i sure would like to live man
and they threw i mean it was a crate to
get me out of there was the
it's a whole different movie all
together those green berets and those
ranchers
and pete pj's that were on that plane on
the hill on the hill the pilots
like spanky he was one of the pilots at
skinny when they came in they came in to
crash
they don't ever talk about that like he
had to crash that bird on the side of a
mountain to get
to get in there and he did it he didn't
give a [ __ ] he's like watch this
boom and just brought it in i mean
there's a gun fight going on from the
top and the bottom
every aircraft we had in country was
wagging like spinning overhead
the specters that's the hand of god you
know or the finger of god
i mean the the weapon rehab man they can
look down on you and just erase you
and they got me out of there i couldn't
believe it
i hadn't thought about that in a while
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience